all right welcome everybody to the first
of what are going to be
two streams today we are standing by for
donald trump at the bottom of the hour
for a very triggered
press briefing i expect trump to be
triggered about a lot of things
including the dnc
um there's just so much there's going to
be a lot uh
trump starting his cancel culture
campaign against goodyear tire
um earlier today we will look at tweets
can you tell do i look different because
there's something very different today
i don't know if people can see it i did
i changed something up today for the
streams
i've had it with the way we've been
doing it my ear
is in my right ear it's been in my left
ear for the last
several weeks i just like to rotate it i
think it's good to do that
okay um it's a rotation of three by the
way which is weird that'll leave you
guys to
imagine what that means okay um
where to start today uh oh okay
other memes as i like to say i did tweet
this um this is a full credit to
producer pat producer pat came up with
this i don't know if you guys have seen
how kaylee maganny will do these tweets
with these green check marks
about all of trump's accomplishments so
we did this one
where everything trump has succeeded at
looking into it very strongly
and that's basically as far as we've
gotten so we've just i just tweeted this
if people want to participate
in a mass oh i wow 300 likes in just a
few like a couple minutes that's great
uh but anyway this is my most recent
tweet
you should be following me on twitter at
d pacman and as many of you know during
the dnc
streams you've actually been able to
take a peek behind the curtain and
you've seen me craft
tweets in real time as i said yesterday
sometimes people wonder how am i so
mediocre on twitter
i've given people a peek behind the
curtain
and shown you how i end up with so many
mediocre tweets donald trump also
tweeting a few hours ago don't buy
goodyear tires they announced a ban on
maga hats get better tires for far
less it's like the does if he really
believed goodyear was offering
subpar tires all along why is he only
now saying it like
if he's known goodyear's tires aren't
very good he could have told us five
years ago to get some different tire
this is what the radical left democrats
do two can play the same game and we
have to start playing
it now okay so i expect that there are
going to be questions about that during
today's press briefing
um if you can protest in person you can
vote in person
uh what else something about drug i
don't even want to deal with that right
now
why are republicans allowing the
democrats to have ridiculous post office
hearings on saturday and monday just
before the convention
oh my god he's extremely extremely
triggered so there's that
and so i assume that there will be
questions about a lot of these things at
the bottom of the hour and then tonight
i'll be back at 8 40 p.m eastern time
for night three of the dnc night two was
better than night one
and tonight we will be hearing from vp
pick kamala harris
we'll be hearing from former uh u.s
president
barack obama so i'll be back at 8 40
tonight and that'll be very very
exciting i also want to say thanks to
judith lynn
as well as petunia smith who just
grabbed memberships on my website i
haven't even pitched membership yet
people already getting memberships and
quabit
cuabidi as swanse has subscribed for two
months with prime
and says pacman churns ideas others
thought were simply unchurnable that's
exactly right
and i actually grilled an idea last week
that a lot of people thought had gone
bad
but i thought it was fine i grilled it
didn't feel sick afterwards it was
perfect
super chats are coming in imagination
arts studio says what are your thoughts
on movie theaters reopening seems like a
bad idea
many states don't reduce capacity to 50
and imax can seat up to and over 500 a
showing yes seems like a
you know let's give it three more four
more months and
um we we hopefully will be in better
shape then
micah gelfind says love your soyboy
stream
davey p man okay looks like we are about
to get live video here
um from the press briefing room yes it
is extremely zoomed in video but it is
video nonetheless
seth barham says are conservatives aware
that by saying the postal service is a
mess they are conceding defeat on
running government like a business
no they are not aware of that
chakuseki says senate intelligence
report report confirms
bulging bloat boy donald lied about
russia can we crowdsource him a shower
cap
for his russian golden showers okay
uh bay photo says trump needs to goya
way if we vote him out 2021 should be a
good year like goodyear tire i like that
donna williams asks do i think trump
will be imprisoned once
he leaves office and is charged for
crimes no
i do not believe he will auntie
pick reinan piccareinen says i like it
when trump sometimes accidentally uses
non-racist terms for coronavirus and
then quickly adds china virus yeah
that is funny and mark cottage says
trump is a train wreck but people love
to hear your commentary on him do you
think your
audience will decrease if he is ousted
yes yes
people i have been saying this for a
long time
if donald trump loses in november this
show is
over okay and we need to remove him in
november i
am i am uh advocating for
the destruction of this program by the
elimination of donald trump
but in all seriousness yeah i think the
next four years
for the show from the perspective of
business will be better if trump wins
but it would be completely immoral to
support trump on that basis so i believe
that we should
remove trump remove trump vote against
trump it won't be that great for the
show but
what i am here to tell you whoa these
are coronavirus numbers that's not what
i wanted
we now okay i hope people are sitting
down here
we are now projected to reach
one million youtube subscribers
on october 29th
70 days away if we do this
this would be the fastest
a hundred thousand subscriber
gra gain that we have ever had
okay and we are currently where are we
right now
we are at 954 wow we just rolled over to
954 we were at 954.
0 000 and
on twitch we're also approaching 50 000.
so
listen we've got to get the growth while
we can do it because if biden wins
good for the country bad for the david
pakman show i'm only half kidding
but it will be a different show
certainly because we will be
advocating for biden to be more left
than trying to remove this mango
malignancy
with which we find ourselves today but
very exciting now on track for
before election day if we can keep it
going october 29th
is when we are slated to hit 1 million
youtube subscribers which is just
absolutely fantastic i don't know what
else to say
and in the meantime ashlad has
subscribed with twitch prime
as we now have a level one hype train
that is happening and um
okay i mean i don't i don't know what
else to say a few other things to look
at here's a couple of clips from the
last few days
somebody clipped this and thought it was
funny let's take a listen
if trump loses fox is laying out a
little bit of the groundwork they're
laying a little pipe so to speak
right okay so somebody liked that one
that was good
and then here is one from my recent
stream
with steven kenneth destiny
bennell the second tv i look forward to
talking and talking to you after a
couple more nights of the dnc yeah
all right take care talk to you soon bye
to destiny's audience yeah
see you later d-pad for the audience wow
wow
what a night i mean i couldn't imagine a
better way to
completely torpedo the evening than
opening up the phone lines
i uh i actually forgot that i had said
that
i i think i might have blacked or
browned it out but um
yeah so that was uh that was quite quite
an evening that was night one of course
of the dnc that's really all i have
today as far as memes i really didn't
get that many
um but remember you can send me
clips uh videos of your pets watching
the show
we got a few of those recently uh memes
graphics images photos
bingo you know anything you want you can
send through the contact form at
davidpakman.com
and then i if it's even remotely good
like even mediocre memes make it onto
the live streams so just something to
think about that you can feel free to
do other super chats coming in
the vegan villainess who's never seen
veganeys she didn't like
says goodyear stated they want to be
apolitical which is smart for business
something trump will never understand
it's on the very long list of things
trump will never understand
um climate change says no matter who
wins the election this summer will be
the coldest summer for the next 500
years
serang sheth says seems like politicians
aren't afraid of the consequences of
their actions anymore
shouldn't they respect and fear the
power of the people what are your
thoughts
well i mean listen if you're talking
about the trump administration if they
are never held accountable why would
they fear that there will be
consequences when there never
are they wouldn't which is why you know
we need to give donny boy a consequence
like he's a little kid
the consequence is voting him out
micah gelfand says how do you sleep at
night when you have so blatantly copied
the majority report's background i know
it's
crazy pair tieren says i would keep
watching your show
even if bernie would be president love
from sweden thanks pair i knew i could
count on you
mark raybould says republican convention
lineup day one scott baio
day two lady who says wearing a mask and
fringes on her first amendment rights
closing day a can of goya beans i
actually haven't looked
do we know what the uh let's see rnc
schedule lineup i don't know
if they've announced okay there is an
article here let's see what the rnc has
announced i'm actually curious
okay monday to be announced okay
tuesday plug-in playbook foursquare
okay so it looks like they've not really
announced anything yet
um let's see rnc 2020 schedule
let's see if there's anything on the
wiki
background format schedule here we go
okay so on tuesday melania trump will be
speaking
the theme will be the land of promise oh
my god for
for day one i looked quickly the theme
is land of heroes i thought it said land
of herpes
i was like that's a weird theme for day
one i would wait until day two or three
for that okay day one
theme is land of heroes nothing's
scheduled yet
day two theme is land of promise melania
trump will be speaking
day three the theme is land of
opportunity
mike pence will be speaking and thursday
will be the theme
land of greatness and donald j
trump will be speaking so we
basically nothing is scheduled yet we
just don't really know anything
specifically
okay guess we just have to wait
uh thanks to artistic simplicity
be nutsern name eric the viking sassy
siren
and ansel for supporting on twitch where
we are in the middle
of a level two hype train
touch engage media says
as a former resident of zimbabwe i've
seen how fast deflation can hit a
country
given the current fed inspired bubble
when do you think it will pop and why
i actually i mean assuming that in the
next six months the virus gets under
control i don't believe it will pop and
i have a few clips explaining why
on my youtube channel david q says can
you please sing for us
no no chris says what are your thoughts
on uber suspending service in california
haven't seen it
uh have a bookmarked article to read
about it
han joby says change your youtube name
to the david pakman show every late
night talk show host
has v in their youtube name david pakman
show sounds amateur hour
i believe our use our url is youtube.com
slash
the david pakman show i believe it is
and
chakaseki says will trump be manic and
sweating more than cardi b's
whap or be down dry and desiccated
like ben shapiro's wife chakuseki's on
fire today i need to i think i need
chakaseki
to takaseki seems like a clever writer
what i should what i need is
i have four monitors here i need a fifth
monitor
just off line of sight where in real
time
chakaseki can put uh jokes up on the
screen for me
and clever lines and i can deliver them
as if i'm that creative
i think that would be useful um
okay big thank you to
daniel turner who's new member number
three today and gwen corey gwen is new
member number four today
during the convention streams we've had
a huge goal of 50
but we're keeping it modest at 25 during
this live stream even though i don't
know why we get like
two times as many viewers during these
live streams than the convention
but you know that's uh
that's a story for a different day i
guess
matt chavez says great 32 video on how
masks work
on youtube oh my god i can't parse the
grammar
great 32 video
i don't know on how masks work on
youtube uploaded today
if anyone wants to share with their kova
denying uncle or just to share to share
okay michael heckins says you freed us
from the worst dictator
sorry we can't help you now to free you
from this idiot
best from berlin germany okay
thank you i appreciate that
neutral music says thoughts on the
gun-toting couple from st
louis speaking at the rnc i think they
might as well have a hologram of roger
ailes
so i heard that the gun-toting couple
was going to speak at the rnc
but i i've not con confirmed it can
anybody tell me if that's actually true
if the st louis gunters are speaking at
the rnc if so i mean that this
we deserve very bad things as a country
if that's happening
leica says hello sam cedar fans glad you
came over to subscribe
my thoughts exactly
um nobody really seems to know for sure
if that couple is speaking people have
heard it okay
lagavulin has subscribed with twitch
prime
dog boy has subscribed with prime
cardboard alpaca has subscribed with
prime
and floofs floofs
has also subscribed with prime oh matt
chavez says
32 is the channel's name okay
all right i apologize i haven't heard of
that
whoa john roberts out of nowhere right
here
wearing a perfectly white mask
that's maybe a signal that the live
stream is going to be starting soon
we are by the way in the 15th
anniversary
year of the david pakman show i know
that it's redundant to say the 15-year
anniversary
but what i mean is this year is the 15th
anniversary of the show
and in fact the exact date is august 22
23rd which is sunday
we are trying to set a single month
record for new members
in this month so if you've been
appreciating the streams and all of the
different content
if you've been with us on the race to a
million subscribers all of the stuff
consider consider grabbing a membership
at joinpackman.com all the info is right
above my head
i believe that the normal prices are
more than reasonable
but if you don't which is fine you can
get a 66
discount off of a membership using the
coupon code
2020 now that'll chop six dollars a
month to two dollars a month
if you pay for the entire year it's like
a dollar eighty three a month
okay if you don't think this and
everything we do is worth a dollar
eighty three a month
then i respectfully disagree with you
and that's it that's fine
um but if you do think it's worth it and
you're you're doing okay
financially i don't want anybody's last
dollar okay i've made that clear
uh consider grabbing a membership
membership is our primary funding source
um and i i've made the case before
and it's all very very exciting and the
website by the way
very powerfully handling all of the
website traffic today we were hacked
last week as many of you would remember
during a stream it was ugly it was ugly
but um you know we fixed it
we fixed it okay
um richard burris says what's your take
on trump and uae israel deal helping his
chance at a second term god forbid i
don't think anybody will remember it ten
days from now i think it'll be a
non-factor
david l says good luck in pogchamps too
yes my first pog champs two match-up is
friday
6 p.m eastern time i will be playing
against the streamer who goes by the
name
it's hafu or it shafu
i believe it's it's hafu 6 pm east
wait yes 6 p.m east 3 p.m
west and that will be friday so i hope
you will join me that will be my first
game i believe i will have the black
pieces to start
and then in the second game i will play
with the white pieces
cyrus palmer says thanks for all you do
david keep it up
micah gelfin says i apologize for my
previous slightly childish super chats
real question
what are your thoughts about biden
harris running hard on competence
character and emotion versus more of a
policy-based pitch
i think given the circumstances it makes
a lot of sense
that's uh that's my sense of it right
now
amy gray sends a 50
super chat dixon side says what's the
groupie scene like
for sub million youtubers it's a pretty
powerful scene
uh yeah yeah it's uh it's big it's very
very big
nasty questions says i just watched my
cameo
birthday video from you shout out to
kelly for the best birthday gift ever i
will continue to watch your show
regardless of the president
thank you for everything you do congrats
on 1 million yes i got a
uh i got booked on cameo by kelly to
send
this user who goes by the name nasty
questions
a birthday greeting and i did it
i did it last week skate shop says my
screen name on my iphone
my screen time on my iphone will be
reduced if trump loses
it will be nice not to have to charge
the damn phone
all the time i hear you chef's pawn says
do you think there's anything trump
could say
that would show his base that he is not
as smart as he thinks
what would that be nah there's a there's
people in trump's base that are
committed to the idea of trump as some
kind of
prodigy uh some kind of genius
and i some of those folks there's just
no way
that their minds will be changed people
asking about the alex morse interview it
did happen today you can already hear it
on today's podcast then the standalone
youtube clip will be published a little
bit
later it was very interesting very
interesting
um let's see
luke stevens has grabbed a youtube
membership underscore
door says new zealand has introduced a
contact tracing app
has the u.s done the same no if not
should they
yes simple questions there
jenna nix says one of my oldest memes of
your show was the 2012 video where were
you where you were wearing winter
clothes happy 15
thanks for your work and dry sense of
humor yeah there was a day back in 20
actually it couldn't have been 2012
because that happened in new york and we
weren't in new york until 2013
but yeah there was a day where the heat
was off in our studio in new york city
and i wore like a puffy coat and a few
other elements of warming
although i don't remember maybe i had a
hat or it might have been full gloves
i don't remember someone's asking me
over on twitch if i'm going to be
on the train wrecks scuffed podcast
i have no clue what that is i don't know
nobody i i'm aware that nobody's invited
me to that i think i would remember that
name but i have no idea what that is
thanks to prior guy for subscribing on
twitch
very much appreciate that uh oh
website memberships are exploding look
at this okay
fernando apalategui
or appala tegui is new member number
five today
jason ellis is new member number six
johnny finley is number seven alex
waddle is number eight per valvic
is number nine and ethan hewitt is
number ten i believe we now have
i believe it's four members with the
first name
pair and of course we have pair tiran
who is regularly
sending super chats from sweden as far
as i knew
all prior members named pair
um were swedish
but you know that could be wrong that
could be wrong i don't know
uh johnny lasagna gaming whoa where did
that go
johnny lasagna gamings has been watching
every day since october of 2016
full and bonus shows somehow never got
to be new member of the day
okay well i'm gonna look into that i
don't know if lasagna is your proper
last name but i can look into that
azar says new zealand went from one case
to nine cases somebody
tell trump it's a 900 increase right
that's when the num when the numbers are
so small
you know it's not so relevant
uh percentage percentages are less
relevant danny thompson says david you
need a lifetime membership option on
your website for a one-time payment of
99
or something that makes sense to you i'm
in so we actually did when we did a uh
an indiegogo campaign indiegogo similar
to kickstarter i don't know if they're
still around
in 20 i believe was 2015.
we offered lifetime memberships for 1500
and i believe two people did it i
believe two people did it i don't think
we would do lifetime for 99 bucks
um and there's there's some math behind
why and it has to do with what we call
the lifetime
value of a member but i don't want to go
all like you know
mba on everybody all of a sudden here
but 99
would not be the we would be taking a
lot of money off the table
if we did a 99 lifetime membership
johnny minogue says rhode island casting
their delegates over spicy calamari was
the most amazing moment of last night we
love our southern neighbors
yes uh calamari i mean just
it's a delightful dish it's a delightful
dish
donna williams says david why do you
think trump won't be prosecuted
because this is not a country that
prosecutes former presidents and i'm not
saying trump doesn't deserve it i'm just
saying he won't be
and if we want to hold him accountable
it's voting him out and embarrassing him
with
a just overwhelming loss in november
anybody saying
we're really going to get ours when
trump gets
carried out you know taken out in
handcuffs it's not going to happen
i just don't see it uh
okay i'm being told trump just tweeted
an update about scheduling
we'll be having a press conference at 5
45 see you in 15.
okay well hopefully hopefully that
happens
zilli doe has subscribed with twitch
prime let me thank a few other new
members
whoa hold on a second um jennifer
baker is new member number 11 today
armin guller is new member number 12.
aquatic llamas is new member number 13
and maurice
o'neill is new member number 14 today
joinedpakman.com also travis lizer
travis lizer is new member number 15.
wow the website's really holding up
which i'm glad to see
uh okay dan alley
where's dan alley wait a second dan ali
says david i saw a trump is just jesus
and jean's bumper sticker and wanted
others to feel my pain any nausea
medication recommendations are welcome
that is vile that's a vile bumper
sticker underscore door says what do you
think of the nra lawsuit legal eagle did
an interesting video on it
did not see unable to comment
jenna nicks says i meant 2012 end of the
world live video
okay tony2xh
says with a 500 swedish kroner
super chat i think that's about 50 bucks
right now
get rid of this fool as president sweden
and eu is laughing at this idiot
love to all of you in the u.s with some
common sense love your channel
tony the butcher tony the swedish
butcher maybe
uh 50 tr01150ng
says alabama launched a contact tracing
app on the third that's great news
jake says does trump play honkers
unlimited i don't know what that means
people are signing up n.h bone says
david will the republican step in on
trump's war against the post office well
louis de joy announced he was stopping
further manipulation of the post office
the question is has the damage already
been done in enough blue states that
they've done what they need to do
and we're screwed anyway so i i did a
story about that today i think we need
to be very careful about the
pronouncement from lewis to joy that
he's not going to make any more changes
he may have already made the changes
that he needs to make
zesty african says from the standpoint
of doing the most
testing what biden-era policy are you
more excited for
hope all is well well listen i'm with
noam chomsky in that
biden's climate platform is the most
progressive we've ever had
uh so i i'm very interested in that just
to pick
pick something lionel ziblat says
waiting for the elections to save us was
a mistake
trump should have been removed not voted
out he can and will
sabotage the election i don't disagree i
just don't know that we have any other
opportunity at this point
um people asking is this the only stream
today
no i will be back with everybody tonight
in fact
three hours from now to the minute i
will be back with dnc
night three dnc night three tonight
we will hear from kamala harris we will
also be hearing from barack obama
tonight
so yeah i will be back with you guys and
that will be really great
um i already did an update on the race
to a million
we are now projected to reach 1 million
youtube subscribers on october 29th
if you want to help this is free i'm
selling you nothing
if you're watching on youtube there's 12
000 of you watching on youtube right now
just hit the subscribe button that's it
that's it
that's it no just just just hit the
subscribe button
uh we could get to 9 55. we're at 9 54
and change
we could instantly get to 955 000
subscribers
um if just 800 of you hit that subscribe
button there's 12 000 watching
and then it will be onward and upward to
9.60 so just think about it smash it
destroy it dissolve it um
crush that subscribe button oh and
hillary clinton tonight as well yes as
people are pointing out
we will be seeing that tonight okay
a lulu girl is a new subscriber at the
soyboy level
year of the cat says any country serious
about china virus response
has done all that trump has done as a
bare minimum
aka new zealand and australia of course
of course i call it coronavirus not
china virus
rad willie says calling it now opening
schools is going to cause another spike
in two weeks of course
we're already seeing it no no question
about that whatsoever
um nick nicholas gur
i know that one so i'm not going to fall
for that one nicholas gur
says dp slams sam cedar
to 1 million subscribers
michael blanco says you think the house
oversight committee questioning the joy
will have any impact or will be
a bunch of grandstanding with no action
taken again the joy has agreed to stop
modifications until the election for
post office service but i believe he
probably has already done what he needs
to do
to help donald trump so it may not be
relevant in the end
waka santana says how do you think the
republican establishment will react to
trump losing if he loses
they will just go back to being the
republicans we knew them to be prior to
trump i think
things sort of tend to return to the
mean i wouldn't expect anything uh too
crazy
i want to say thank you to jinger for
subscribing with twitch prime
thumb duke butt load of butts has
subscribed on twitch
kritma has subscribed with prime so has
sherry or shari as well
appreciate that solar says what's the
over
under on trump lies during this
conference tonight i would expect trump
would could easily get through 250 lies
uh during today's press briefing for
sure 250 trump can do in his sleep
oh boy phone's going crazy here uh
joan brissett has signed up bk says love
your live react thoughts on aoc speech
at dnc
i thought it was fine i didn't really
find myself reacting very strongly to it
didn't didn't think much of it one way
or the other but it was it was fine
robert sunden has signed up david q says
who would you pick for debate if you
were granted one hour of their time and
on what subject
i have no idea i'm terrible at questions
like that
aquatic llamas says i work in the
airlines
and this coronavirus stuff is absolutely
brutal what was the second airline
bailout about
if you've heard about it have not heard
about it have not heard about it
um kumar says having hillary on shows
the dems didn't change a bit
and may likely lose the election the
dems need to part ways with the
clintons not a unique perspective i've
been hearing that from a bunch of people
the dude says hillary needs to crawl
back under whatever rock she's been
hiding under she has done enough already
by dawn 2020
cinnamon beard atahios
darka saran have subscribed on twitch
with twitch prime why do i struggle with
twitch username so much it's crazy
emily swaboda has subscribed on youtube
so has feisty fan which i very much
appreciate this
was if you're just joining us you've not
missed anything
other than memes uh this was originally
scheduled for 5 30.
donald trump tweeted moments 15 minutes
ago that he was 15 minutes away from the
start and we are now
standing by uh for this press briefing
we expect questions about trump calling
for a goodyear boycott
i i expect so there were people tweeting
me
do we think it's going to be upper trump
or downer trump
is it sudafed trump or benzodiazepine
trump
for some reason i think trump's going to
be hopped up today it's been low energy
trump for a little while but monday
tuesday he had these sort of proto
rallies in different
places and i think trump's going to come
out firing today a lot of all caps
tweets today
also makes me think trump is going to
come out hot he's going to be coming in
hot
that's my uh that's my prediction let me
say a few other new member thank yous
because they are getting very explosive
otto ku is new member number 15.
william joyner's number 16 today judy
harris is number 17.
nina finch is number 18 and patrice
walker is new member number 19 today
very much appreciate that uh
let's see here
ryan nicholson asks where do you think
the uk us special relationship will go
if trump gets a second term well i don't
think it will be as bad as it would be
with a normal british prime minister
because boris is just wacky enough that
it'll probably be
somewhat of a normal relationship but if
trump got another four years
and the uk had a normal prime minister
it would be
a dramatic dramatic breakdown in
relationship for sure
james acosta has retracted a message
carl says is there actually beef with
you and sam
no kind of triggering your more
credulous fans like me
you know i was texting with sam the
other day and i was saying
no matter how many times i say that the
entire beef is a joke people still email
me
furious about the whole thing they're
taking it seriously and sam said yeah me
too
he's also getting emails but it it's
just a joke guys it's we're kidding
around you know
it's there's no need to email me
everything's okay
johnny kane says have you heard about
texas backlog cases over 7 000
lost positives being reported since
sunday in dallas county alone i did
i did read about that you know
no surprise pacman's little bot
wants to know when the next chess
tournament is not for a while because
i'm
training for pog champs too and i
also um i s the tournament starts on
friday
so at least until probably it'll be
september pog champs
ends in early september so i may do the
tournament what i actually may do is
we've decided at the show we will be
taking a mental health break
for a week in the middle of september so
once we're past
the conventions but before the debates
because i don't i don't
you i'm not going to miss those debates
you can be sure about that
in the middle we're going to take a week
off and during that week off
i may just do a chess tournament for fun
so
i'll let you guys know about that keith
stone
says have you covered brett weinstein's
unity 2020 recently yeah i've gotten
five questions about it
uh sounds interesting to think about not
for 2020 i mean it's going to be trump
or biden
and the election people are about to
start voting in a few weeks in some
states so
it's not super interesting to me right
now uh
but you know we can talk about it for
2024 one step at a time
thomas ganter says germany financed an
open source
hold on a second germany financed and
open sourced
a tracing app months ago it even
sports multiple languages cdc should
grab it off github
yeah that's not happening just
it's i if you're yeah it seems like
you're german
you may not understand how things
function here but that's that's not
going to happen
maddie ice says i've never been born
more embarrassed david come back
calamari hope all is well otherwise
cheers everyone
chauncey jones has signed up chef's pawn
says in your opinion is the damage trump
has done to america be fixed
is the damage trump has done to america
be fixed can it be fixed i think you
mean
if so how do we fix it other than just
voting well it's voting but not just for
president
it's at the uh local level as well
i must have a dozen clips about how to
affect change in our communities so i
encourage you to check those out
jacob ball just came in out of nowhere
with a 50 super chat saying pacman said
the beef is fake
but cedar says not to trust pacman
so it must be real okay not bad
uh big bro cook is firing a shot across
the bow
with the message majority to a million
listen i i said before uh
this is not zero sum you can subscribe
to me
and to sam cedar it's not there's no
reason it has to be one or the other
um and we are wow somehow we've got 14
000 people watching but only 200
are i'm wondering are there people
watching on youtube
who are not already subscribers
what i'm trying to figure out is whether
the live
streams are hitting mostly existing
subscribers
i'm going to check the youtube chat
momentarily here
for whatever reason youtube is always
about 15 seconds delayed beyond
twitch i've never figured out why
because it's it's beyond me
but let's see what people have to say
a lot of yosemites okay
wow big delay big big big delay
oh my goodness people are bots
a lot of weird stuff
okay it seems a lot of people don't know
if they're subscribed or not okay well
that's
weird weird but i can't do much about it
so we will continue
also by the way there are 1600 people
watching on facebook
and i because i have no like chat system
with facebook i often forget about you
guys i appreciate you guys as well
and the the streams have actually been
doing pretty well on facebook and there
are 1600 people
there's more people watching on facebook
than on twitch uh it's just too bad that
the facebook interface doesn't really
lend itself to
the type of interaction that you know
modern users of the internet sort of
take for granted at this point
all right let's continue seeing what
else is on people's minds thanks to
sound doctor and jack attack
as well as the silent one and luigi
gaswaldo for subscribing with
oh my god three minutes later now people
are we do we have a three minute delay
on youtube that is insane
thanks to everybody subscribing on
twitch it looks like
the uh they are getting ready here for
donald trump they're pointing the camera
towards the door
if nothing else so we are probably very
very close john howell says via super
chat that the david pakman show is worth
more than a dollar eighty-three
that's good feisty fan asks what this
press briefing is about
i have no idea literally no idea
jacob ball we got to already rockwell
says trump continues to imply china
attack the u.s
if he believes that why has he not made
any official declaration of war with
china what are your thoughts
uh yeah who knows what trump really
believes
marisa derry says what are your feelings
on candidates that support
canon q anon kanan
theories being elected when trump does
not win will the stench of this
administration stay
yes and in fact remember if trump gets
62 million votes and loses in november
we still have 62 million people who
voted for trump that we have to deal
with in this country
right they're not going away and so that
is uh
that is a big big problem regardless
amy says we need to vote and take over
the senate with a good margin
yes and keep the house margin with that
if trump wins he's impeached and removed
there's the possibility that trump could
be impeached uh
um again but let's not get ahead of
ourselves
let's just work on removing donald trump
i think that's the way to go
jacob ball back again perhaps the boys
are confusing your numbers
i don't even know what that means
f dub says hashtag tag cold
feet cedar vk says trump today feel
bigly goodyear bad
post orifices orifices or you know
sad trump self-talk one minute before
sniffing to the podium oh boy
i don't even know what that's about
jamie mclean says i've just realized i'm
not
subscribed i thought i was as i got
recommended every day for the fast past
couple of months i am now with
notifications yes
please check if you're watching on
youtube
is the subscribe button enabled if it is
it means you're not subscribed and you
can very powerfully press that button
and uh i i honestly my goal is
with this stream and with the dnc night
three stream
we could actually get to 960 000
subscribers by midnight
it's possible it's a stretch goal as we
say in the biz
but um it actually could happen that's
how crazy what's going on right that's
how explosive the situation is
um yeah
okay a lot of the okay let's go to trump
here he is coming in let's take a listen
oh boy thank you very much
before i provide an update on our
continued progress against the
china virus i'd like to discuss our
latest actions against
the iranian regime
i'm directing the secretary of state
mike pompeo
to notify the u.n security council that
the united states intends to restore
virtually all of the previously
suspended united nations sanctions
on iran it's a snap back
not uncommon two years ago i withdrew
the united states from the disastrous
iran nuclear deal which was a product of
the obama
biden foreign policy adhered to it a
failure like
few people have seen in terms of the
amount of money we paid for absolutely
nothing and a short-term deal
this deal remember iran didn't violate
the deal there was no reason to bail on
it
to around 150 billion to be exact plus
1.8 billion in cash which i don't know
that the president had the authority to
give
gave 1.8 billion in cash just another
great
deal that turned out to be a total
disaster
that would have uh funded all of the
chaos and the bloodshed and the terror
in the region
and all throughout the world and i won't
say anything because i don't like saying
it but
iran doesn't have so much money to give
to the world anymore to the terrorists
to give to al qaeda and
various other groups of people that they
were funding they have to
keep their own regime together and it's
not easy for them
and okay if and when i win the election
within
the first month iran will come to us and
they are going to be asking for a deal
so quickly because they are doing very
poorly
but that deal was a disaster 150 billion
dollars 1.8 billion dollars
in care now why can't he just do the
deal now why didn't he do it last year
the year before
they are the short expiring starting to
expire already
it's terminated but it would have if we
didn't terminate it
start to expire very shortly incoherent
good deal was the deal we made with uae
and
israel and by the way other countries i
will tell you now want to come into that
deal
countries that you wouldn't even believe
want to come into that deal correct
we don't believe it and all of a sudden
you're going to have peace in the middle
east and you couldn't have done it with
this ridiculous
iran nuclear deal as they call it that
president obama made
along with sleepy joe biden i
impose the toughest ever sanctions on
iran
and this has caused great difficulty for
them
giving money to terrorist organizations
and if they do they'll have hell to pay
earlier this year i ordered the strike
that took out the world's number one
terrorist
kasem solomani okay in addition to
previously terminating leader and
founder of isis
oh my god previously terminated
where is that coming from oh sorry the
two
leading paris by far
in the world the founder of isis nobody
even talks about that
and we also defeated we now have 100
of the isis caliphate in syria
when i took over it was a mess it was a
total mess it was
they were all over the place my
administration will not allow this
iran nuclear situation
to go on they will never have
a nuclear weapon so understand what's
going on
trump's trying to take back the
narrative to seem presidential and to
seem tough
and to pretend like the country's not
falling apart to the
iran deal it was clear that the united
states would always have the right to
restore the u.n sanctions that will
prevent iran from developing a nuclear
weapon
we paid a fortune for a failed concept
and a failed policy a policy that would
have made it impossible to have peace in
the middle east
here at home through operation
legend we are confronting
the wave of crime and democrat run
american cities that's absolutely
shocking
when you look at what's funny trump's
like things are terrible in cities now
re-elect me for four more years
sometimes los angeles
democrat run cities they're a mess
because they don't get it
either they don't get it or there's
something that nobody else understands
we've deployed more than 1 000
additional federal agents to
help these democrat run disasters we
just
have done this we have to give them a
hand
and we can stop it immediately like a
portland would be
so easy to stop would stop it
immediately we
only sent in some homeland people who
were great by the way to
save the courthouse because it would
have been blown up or burned down
and they did that very easily but if we
were
called upon we would send in cold
whether it's
homeland whether it's fbi guys what the
hell is he talking about
and we'd send him in quickly we would
eradicate it just like happened
in minneapolis as soon as they were
called in they should have been called
in
a lot sooner you would have had far less
damage today we announced that
operation legend has successfully
resulted in nearly 1
500 arrests already bad ones bad ones
really bad people prosecutions and
prison sentences will follow and they'll
be very long time in prison
for what they've done to these cities
most cities are well-run most of the
nation is well-run
and the areas that we're talking about
are all in all cases run by democrats
usually
radical left leaning democrats like in
new york or in portland
we've made arrests in kansas city
chicago cleveland detroit milwaukee st
louis memphis and albuquerque for many
violent crimes including
gun crimes arson and 91
murders we're also using the full power
of the federal government
to defeat as you know the china virus
new cases have declined in 80 percent
of the jurisdictions in the past week 80
percent new zealand by the way had a big
outbreak they have nine kids in other
countries that were held up to try and
make us look natural look because we've
done an incredible job but
they're having a lot of outbreaks but
they'll be able to put them out and we
put them out
the hospitalization rate has fallen in
our country
54 since its peak in
april 54 older americans are still the
most vulnerable to
the virus 92 percent of deaths have
occurred among those 55 and older
only 2.7 of deaths have occurred among
those 44 years
think of that 44 years and younger so
44 years old and younger
only 2.7 percent of deaths have
occurred and many of those
people had pre-existing conditions they
had problems
heart diabetes and other problems
but many of those so think of that only
2.7 percent
under 44 years of age excess
mortality in europe this year is 33
percent
higher than the united states that's a
crazy compe
the math of that comparison is crazy
nations uh south korea you've been
reading about south korea doing well
well they just had a very big breakout
but they'll be able to solve the problem
we must all remain vigilant and continue
to exercise extreme caution
around those at highest risk as we know
multiple colleges and universities
announced
that they would suspend in-person
teaching
and we have learned one thing there's
nothing like campus there's nothing like
being with the teacher as opposed to
being on a
computer board it's uh been proven a lot
better
it's a lot better the ideas are
wonderful but you're not going to learn
by the way what the hell does it do so
nevertheless certain colleges and
universities have announced that they
would suspend the in-person teaching
for older people and individuals with
underlying conditions the china virus is
very dangerous but
for university students the likelihood
of severe illness is
less than or equal to the risk of a
seasonal few
a seasonal flu and
the seasonal flu happens and comes and
it goes and
anybody else feeling confident seeing
this but people don't talk about it
in the same way and they shouldn't
but if you look at that the odds are
less than or equal to instead of saving
lives the decision to
close universities could cost lives it
is significantly safer for students to
live with other young people than to go
home and
spread the virus to older americans not
if you're quarantining and being
responsible
and the shutdown thing is
causing tremendous depression
for those places that are still shut
down you look at certain
areas that in all cases
democrat run still shut down and their
numbers
aren't even good but causing tremendous
depression suicide
drugs alcohol abuse
a lot of problems are being caused
probably far more
i would say scott than is caused by the
virus itself now that we understand the
virus completely untrue
colleges should take reasonable
precautions
students who feel sick should not attend
class and should limit
social interaction as they would for any
other illness
and universities should implement
measures to imagine
living in a country with a real leader
and then someone says hey
watch an hour of this for a moment what
do you think those people are thinking
in high risk settings and to prevent
transmission period but especially in
nursing homes
and to care for the vulnerable and our
elderly which
could fit into that definition of
who is vulnerable we have tremendous
unused testing capacity in our country
we have a tremendous
unusual yet it still takes five to seven
days to get results
a lot of other nations are very
impressed with they tell us
in our path forward we will continue to
follow a science-based approach
to protecting the high risk while
enabling healthy americans to safely go
back to work and school
our country will be open our country is
getting open quickly or
stock markets are almost back to where
they were prior to the
china virus disaster coming in
and uh i want to thank you all for being
here and we'll take some uh
questions yep wow during the pandemic
uh the q anon movement has been appears
to be gaining a lot of followers
can you talk about what you think about
that and what you have to say
to people who are following this
movement right now well i don't know
much about the movement
other than i understand they liked me
very much
which i appreciate but i don't know much
about the movement
i have heard that it is gaining in
popularity and from what i hear these
are people that
when they watch the streets of portland
when they watch what happened in new
york city in just the last six or seven
months but this was starting
even four years ago when i came here
almost four years so what he hears he
likes
uh these are people that don't like
seeing what's going on in
places like portland and places like
chicago
and new york and other cities and states
and i've heard these are people that
love our country and they just don't
like seeing it he's endorsing q and a i
don't know
really anything about it other than he
likes them they
do supposedly like me
and they also would like to see
problems in these areas like especially
the areas that we're talking about
go away because there's no reason that
democrats can't run a city
and if they can't we will send in all of
the federal
whether it's troops or law enforcement
whatever they'd like customers about
curating
about their problem in 24 hours or less
okay
at the crux of the theory it is this
belief that
you are secretly saving the world from
this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like something
you're doing you are behind well i
haven't
i've haven't heard that but uh
is that supposed to be a bad thing or a
good thing i knew it
if if i can help save the world from
problems i'm
willing to do it i'm willing to put
myself out there and we are actually
we're saving the world from the oh he's
saying he's doing it
he needs to be philosophized that will
destroy
this country and when this country is
gone
the rest of the world would follow wow
the rest of the world would follow
that's the importance of this country
and when you look at some of the things
that these people are saying
with uh he hasn't heard about the fact
that he's saving the world from a ring
of pedophilia
but it sounds good to him but he just
poured right into our country
no testing no nothing you know you talk
about testing
no testing mexico as you know has a very
high rate of infection the wall is now
going to be next week 300 miles long
our numbers are extraordinary on the
border
had that and this is through luck
perhaps more than talent although the
talent is getting it built when one
party refuses to allow it you don't hear
talk about the wall anymore
but i will say this um
we need strength in our country the
question was about q anon remember
much weakness yes mr president you have
been very
bullish on the promise of convalescent
plasma
to treat coronavirus the fda appeared to
be
on the brink of issuing an emergency use
authorization for convalescent plasma
please call it some top officials at the
nih that there wasn't
enough evidence to go ahead with that
the fda has put that on pause
your reaction to that and do you believe
that convalescent plasma should be in
he's goading him well i hear great
things about it john that's all i can
tell you
and it could be a political decision
because you have a lot of people over
there that don't want to rush things
because they want to
they want to do it after november 3rd
and you've heard that one before
but i've heard fantastic things about
convalescent plasma
and i've heard numbers way over 50
there's number one
uh success and people are dying
and we should have it approved if it's
good and i'm hearing it's good i heard
from people at the fda that it's good so
we'll see i'm going to check that right
after this conference
my understanding that the white house
will encourage the nih and the fda to
get this out there as quickly as well
the numbers are as good as i'm hearing i
mean i'm hearing over 50
and that's very good and we've approved
certain things are 31 and that's okay
too that's not bad and it's really had a
tremendous disappear but no i
i have you're telling me something right
now that surprises me
but we'll check it out right after this
turned about it away
i don't want delays i don't want people
dying
i don't want people dying yeah please mr
president i want to ask you about your
tweet earlier today on goodyear it was
essentially calling for
a boycott on two year tires do you want
the federal government
to stop buying and using goodyear
product as well and is there anything
i'm not happy with
because what they're doing is playing
politics and the funny thing hey you
know what i want to do let's just switch
here so we can see the reporters okay
i don't want delays i don't want people
dying
i don't want people dying yep mr
president i want to ask you about your
tweet earlier
today on goodyear it was essentially
calling for a boycott on two year tires
do you want the federal government to
stop buying
and using goodyear product as well and
is there anything i'm not happy with
goodyear because what they're doing is
playing politics and the funny thing is
the people that work
for goodyear i can guarantee you i poll
very well with all of those great
workers in goodyear
and when they say that you can't have
blue lives matter
you can't show a blue line you can't
wear a maga
hat but you can have other things that
are could you just ban political items
uh there's something wrong with the top
of goodyear
and what the radical left does is they
make it impossible for people to do
business
if they're republican or if they're
conservative
they put out all sorts of effort don't
shop there
they do vicious things not so different
than what you saw on the streets
of portland two nights ago very
different do you invest
that's up to people but i wouldn't
recommend it if they if they want to
hold
political speech if they want to let you
not do
what everybody's doing if they want to
wear
a maga hat or if they want to wear a
blue life you know what blue lives
matter right that's police
men and women uh oh okay that's a
terrible thing
that's a terrible thing so they're using
their power over
these people and these people want to
wear whatever it is that we're talking
about you know that
and so i would be very much uh
in favor of people don't want to buy
there and you know what they'll be able
to
get a good job because we set a jobs
record over the last
quarter as you know the most jobs people
don't want to buy or people don't want
to work what is he talking about now
i think it's disgraceful that they did
this please go ahead
yes mr president you've said that the
arrest of jimmy lie
in hong kong is quite a terrible thing
do you have a message for jimmy why has
your administration spoken directly with
him is your state department working for
his release well i send him best wishes
i hear he's a wonderful gentleman is
that epoch
certainly a brave man um and i send him
best wishes with that being said
because of that and obviously what
happened in hong kong we've taken all of
the
vast amounts of money that we used to
subsidize hong kong we essentially
subsidized
hong kong by giving them all sorts of
incentives wow
and that's what made hong kong the
exchange and
business in hong kong successful i've
taken it all back
that means that the united states is
going to do a lot more business you know
we
at we we really gave them tremendous
incentive
and subsidy in order that they be
successful for freedom
but now that the freedom obviously seems
to
have been taken away we will keep all of
the incentives that we were given them
which is billions and billions of
dollars
and all of that business will come into
our country
including the new york stock exchange
and nasdaq and
nasdaq it'll all come here but i feel
badly for him
because i hear he's a good person i
don't know but i hear he's a good person
obviously a very brave person did you
have something good
yes sir thank you mr president uh with
the iraqi prime minister coming in
tomorrow
uh what about oh my god the iraqi prime
minister is coming in tomorrow to meet
with you
and how do you feel about this notion
that iraq can once again
become the buffer between iranian
influence and russian influence in the
middle east do you feel that under this
prime minister
uh that that's possible once again well
this is a man that i get along with very
well
we're largely out of iraq we're down to
very few soldiers i said we're getting
out of these endless wars these
uh ridiculous endless wars we should
have never been there in the first place
i think it was the worst decision made
in the history of our country should
have never remember he went on the
howard stern show and said he would have
gone into iraq so that's
you know this is another revisionist
history
in getting out it's very sticky getting
out and some people agree and
many people don't agree but i think
most people very much agree uh we're
doing
very well in our negotiations with
afghanistan we're getting out we're down
to a
much smaller number of people left there
and you know i greet men and women
coming home and coming home after
they've been hit i've also
greeted many many at dover we did many
bodies coming back in
and we've been there
basically policemen were acting as
police as opposed to soldiers
and they're going to have to police
their own states and they've been doing
that for thousands of years
but it's time after 19 years that our
soldiers come home they've done an
incredible job but
you know they don't they're not allowed
to fight to win
and and maybe they shouldn't be because
a lot of the people it's not their fault
but with the taliban and with uh
going to iraq again we're down in
afghanistan
uh very low numbers and that'll be uh
taking place and
i let them know do anything and you'll
be hit like you've never be
been hit before what uh so we're
we're doing very well syria the same
thing remember when i took what
all of the soldiers off of the border
between
syria and turkey right and everybody
said oh this is those two years ago it's
a long time ago they said oh this is
terrible
terrible terrible we're going to leave
why do we have our soldiers between
syria
and turkey turkey can definitely take
care of itself i have a
very good relationship with president
erdogan and
syria has been fighting forever and i
say why are we guarding their border and
i
brought our soldiers back home i got
them out and guess what nothing's
happened
they've been fighting like they have
been for a thousand years okay
nothing's happened and nobody mentions
that everybody said this is going to be
a disaster there's no disaster nothing's
happened
what are earth are you talking so we're
uh getting out of the endless wars
and we are building a military the likes
of which the world has never seen two
and a half trillion dollars we've spent
and we hopefully don't ever have to use
it but we want to
focus on a much bigger picture because
we have a much bigger picture
it's uh when you look at what china's
doing when you look at what
russia is doing when you look at what
some other countries are doing
we want to be ready just in case there
is a catastrophe we don't want to see
that we don't want to ever use it
okay we've rebuilt our military
new missiles new rockets and new tanks
and new everything new everything two
and a half trillion all made in the usa
everything's new
and we've uh upgraded incredibly our
nuclear
capability and some of them do you guys
remember the question
it needed new strength and we've we've
upgraded it very very significantly
i mean to a level that nobody would even
believe and hopefully we don't
you pray to god we never have to use it
okay
but we've never been in a position where
we've been this strong please
thank you so much um i wanted to ask you
about the middle east i have a couple
questions
um you mentioned that other countries
are interested in
following suit uh yes having to do with
uae
and israel exactly so is do you expect
that
saudi arabia will join and i do
yes and also uh the emiratis have
expressed interest in the f-35
um do you think that that should be
something that they could look forward
to in the future
is there some sort of title i think
they've definitely got the money to pay
for it you know it's nice because uh
usually when we a lot of times we make
deals they don't have 10 cents these
countries we deal with and give it to
them
like how about paying this back later
but they never pay because they don't
have the money
no they have the money and they they
would like to order quite a few f-35s
it's the greatest fighter jet in the
world as you know before
stealth can it go 17 times the speed of
sound
makes it very difficult i was asking a
pilot what do you think is better this
one this one that one
talking about russian planes chinese
planes
he said well the advantage we have is
you can't see it
right so when we're fighting they can't
see us trump literally thinks these
plans are invisible he's not invisible
to radar big advantage to me
to these guys you know they look by the
way i said
to these pilots that i meet they look
better than tom cruise trump's surprised
he can even see the pilots he thought
the pilots would be cloaked too
but these these people are amazing and i
i speak to them a lot about it what do
you think you know as i go around to the
various
places i saved the big one in florida as
an example that was a big one
knocked down pretty much by the
hurricane so
uh i spent a lot of time on that and
it's the greatest plane in the world
uh one thing about that kind of thing
technology high technology
greatest plane doesn't last long
somebody comes up with something else
but we're always the one to come up with
something else
so yeah they'd like to buy f35s we'll
see what happens
it's under review but they made a great
uh
a great they're going to look at it very
strongly a piece of the middle east even
the new york times thought it was an
incredible deal can you imagine that
tom friedman had a very nice thing to
say about it i spoke to him about it he
thought it was terrific
and and it is terrific i see a lot of
countries coming in fairly quickly
and when you have them all in uh
ultimately iran will come into
there'll be peace in the middle east
that will be nice iran will be
very much neutralized they never thought
this could have happened
and with the horrendously stupid
iran deal signed by obama
and sleepy this could have never
happened
on the goodyear issue you ride on
goodyear tires
in the presidential limousine right if
there were an alternative
would you want those tires swapped out
yeah i would do that i would i would
swap them out based on what i heard
we'll see what happens look you're gonna
have a lot of people not wanting to buy
that product anymore
and uh they'll buy from a competitor
made in the usa too okay please he's
gonna switch to toys r us tires
except from obama's speech that he will
give later at the democratic convention
um show that he will he says that he
hoped that you would take the
being president more seriously once you
had the job and discover
reverence for democracy and then he said
i quote but he never did
what is your reaction you know uh when i
listen to that and then i see the horror
horror that he's left us the stupidity
of the transactions that he made look
what we're doing we have our great
border wall we have secured we're done
we have topping a lot of ours today the
uae deal which has been universally
praised praised by people that
aren't exactly uh fans of donald trump
for various reasons i don't know why
can't be my personality but
they're not fans right and when i look
at
what we have now look at how bad he was
how
ineffective a president he was he was so
ineffective
so terrible slowest growing recovery in
the history i guess since 1929
can you imagine a dumber claim than this
virus came in we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world and
now we're doing it again i'm
gonna have to do it a second time we're
doing it again
hard to believe we're doing very well
you heard the numbers they're way way
down on the
on the virus but when you look at the
kind of numbers that we're producing on
the stock markets we're almost at the
level in fact nasdaq
and s p are higher than they were
at their highest point prior to the
china virus coming and the plague
coming in now president obama did not do
a good job
and the reason i'm here is because of
president obama and joe biden
because if they did a good job i
wouldn't be here and probably if they
did a good job i wouldn't have even run
i would have been very happy
i enjoyed my previous life very much
well maybe he can return
to it very soon stand before you as
president thank you all very much
what a ridiculous year i mean i for me
the craziest moment was
where he said positive things about q
anon
that i think was sort of like the
highlight for me um
unbelievable unbelievable listen guys
i'm back in just over two hours with
night three of the dnc
if you want to be notified when i go
live if you're watching on youtube hit
the subscribe button there's 23
000 people watching on youtube if you're
watching on twitch hit the follow button
so that you'll be notified when i go
live in just a couple of hours
i will see everybody then very strongly
as you know
you